[Musique]
bonjour william
bonjour et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
vidéo je suis en compagnie de william a
kind of seven et j'avais envie
aujourd'hui de parler des différentes
variations de chifoumi mais vraiment on
va en parler aujourd'hui vous allez voir
plein de jeux de doute qu'on peut faire
cet été c'est peut-être misant pour seul
ou à plusieurs le hic générique c'est le
vent version buchy oui avec fabien de
ses hommes alors aujourd'hui on va se
faire le chiffre ni classique on va voir
une variation a4 a5 qui symbole à cette
symbole ça monte très haut je te ferai
voie après mais on va aussi voir de jeu
dans le jeu qu'ils font en mongolie est
un jeu que j'ai découvert là en faisant
des recherches pour cette vidéo qui
s'appelle la moule la mouche l'amour
quoi l'amour
non mais ça vient de l'amour à bella et
c'est du patois italien et c'est un truc
vraiment fou je te ferai voir une vidéo
je vous ferai voir un extrait vidéo des
compétitions qui se passe en corse en
italie dans le sud de la france c'est
des tares et à haut niveau à web avec
l'huile avec les mram étaient pas prêts
quoi juste avant de commencer tu savais
que j'avais un partenariat aujourd'hui
pas du tout alors je vous parlais de
dispaître ya quelque chose que vous ne
savez pas c'est que on est en train de
changer de locaux c'est d'ailleurs pour
ça que ça résonne ça résonne loïc oui ça
résonne un petit peu c'est à dire que
toute la vidéo filmée avec doc seaman
c'est dans les anciens locaux ce qu'on
appelle déjà les anciens et là on est
dans les nouveaux alors n'est pas encore
vraiment installés mais il ya dix plaies
qui nous a proposé travailler avec eux
et c'est plutôt cool parce que nous on
voulait décoré ce bureau guy sprites et
des posters de plusieurs tailles
différentes à ces détails qu'on a pris
pour décorer ici mais il ya énormément
davantage déjà c'est en métal donc c'est
super résistants ils ont plus de huit
cent mille références au catalogue
en clair tu trouve à peu près tout ce
que tu veux mais l'intérêt où on a
vraiment kiffé au delà de pouvoir
choisir tout ce qu'on voulait c'est le
montage qui est ultra facile en gros
vous avez un petit autocollant de
protection vous mettez un aimant dessus
qui est collée sur le truc de protection
comme ça ça s'enlève facilement et après
vous pouvez bâtir un temps va switcher
vous pouvez passer d'un poster à l'autre
mais genre en deux 2 sait plus trop cool
donc nous l'idée qu'on a avec le hic
c'est à chaque fois dans les vidéos
qu'on va tourner ici
comment d'aidé disponibles qui sont
adaptés et on va tourner je partais sur
une quarantaine de tableaux qu'on va
changer au fur et à mesure à chaque fois
sur les sujets qu'on aura ça c'est
clairement mon préféré c'est pas tant
pour le décor que pour le décor du
bureau parce qu'on a une salle de
réunion qui est sur le thème du retour
vers le futur
on vous fera voir tout ça sur instagram
pr non négligeable à chaque fois que
vous achetez un despite il ya nappe qui
est planté et ça vous savez comme je dis
vous avez un lien qui est dans la
description avec mon lien vous avez 30 %
de réduction pendant une semaine à
compter de la sortie de la date de
sortie de cette vidéo la passe hélas
cette première semaine après vous aurez
encore 20 % de réduction
tout le temps mais là vous êtes 30% vous
pouvez en profiter mais je vous
recommande quand même quoi qu'il arrive
que vous en vouliez ou pas de cliquer
sur le lien dans la description pour
aller voir parce que le catalogue
il est juste ouf vous tapez les thèmes
que vous aimez que ce soit des trucs
généraliste de pop culture de signer de
tout ce que vous voulez et vous allez
voir la collection est impressions et du
coup je deviens clients chez eux parce
que je vais continuer à renouveler le
fond du décor et on vous fera bientôt
voir les nouveaux bureaux un peu mieux
que ça bons chiffres ont mis classique
tu connais donc ces pierres non s et es
beau tu as bien travaillé ta vidéo le
puits de comptes parc depuis le combat
en fait si du coup il compte en
allemagne et c'est une variation à 4 ok
pour le coup parce que moi aussi je suis
toujours dis ouais le puits c'est un
truc de tricheurs et ou non c'est juste
une variation à 4 sauf que le problème
c'est que c'est une variation
déséquilibre est parce que le puits il
peut lutter contre trop de gestes alors
qu'il ya qu un seul geste qui le tue
ouais tu vois donc faut toujours faire
le clown donc faut toujours faire de la
feuille parce que tout le monde va faire
le puits ouais ouais mais moi je ferai
les ciseaux parce que tout le monde va
faire la fête puisque tout le monde fait
le plus mais tu tombes dans le puits et
cuisine ouais mais non parce que j'ai
coupé la feuille avance parce qu'il a
cru que j'allais faire le savez de sa la
vidéo est là on va enfin je vais rentrer
dans son esprit voudrais penser à ces
fourmis classique en trois points pour
se chauffer un peu toi tu fais comment
comme ça un de trop non meta bank tqb
savent en dessous avant ce week-end
alors chifoumi chifoumi un point pour
toi si phoumy chifoumi chifoumi tifo mi6
fomi kefu me soit 2 2
c'est ça ok insomnies
c'est faux me grâce est bon je savoure
un peu ok on passe quand même pris des
deux premiers points mais ok mais tu
crois mais si c'était un bo deux jours
gagne quand tu joue au poker et que tu
te fais sortir
bah non je crois un peu après est ce que
tu connais la série the big bang theory
wii est dedans ils ont inventé une
variation à 5 qui complètement équilibré
donc c'est le chiffre me classique sauf
que tu rajoutes spock
ouais et le désert et le lézard et tu
fais commence le lézard et notamment
pour le chiffon me à 5 on rajoute deux
éléments spock et le lézard alors spock
yb à la pierre et les ciseaux la pierre
elle bat toujours les ciseaux mais elle
va également le lézard parce qu'apple
l'écrabouiller le lézard lui il va deux
choses la feuille et spock et enfin la
feuille qui passe ok c'est pas tellement
pourquoi est aussi la pierre en gros
c'est très équilibré puisque chacun bat
deux d'entre eux et se font battre par
deux d'entre eux voilà mais ça c'est un
jeu vous pouvez faire cet été tu vois
parce que comme on y en a toujours
marché passé un stage me concentre ok
shi fu mais je crains les déserts exact
c'était un bureau j'ai gagné et il faut
me c'est quoi ça non mais c'est quoi toi
pour trois bassins
je note avec les doigts écartés brest
mac mais je sais pas perso k-way mais
alors ça c'est une feuille vous montre
moi que je sais pas le faire j'ai jamais
lu
shi fu mi l'a7 et fils mais non mais
c'est une feuille
non mais dans une feuille chiffonnée chi
trung ly edge désintégrant la feuille en
or j'ai déjà qu'il a perdu 6 2 bravo
merci totalement due au hasard
je crois que pendant qu'on t'a posé mais
je fais quoi
attend il ya la version canadienne
j'ai pas les gestes mais apparemment
chez vous nos amis du québec
vous faites le roche papier ciseaux
allumettes bol de toilette bol de
toilette live comme ça mais moi je me
dis peut-être ali m cadettes allumettes
c'est ça ouais ou ça est bonne le bol de
toilette je connaissais tout à quoi bon
en accueillir que l'allumette et spock
où m et donc s'il allumait tse spock et
ça c'est le lézard l'allumette tombe
dans le bol chiffres ou grosch chief
aussi nos balles à sa coupe
non voici abassi harris poll canadien
mais c'est pas logique ou si vous mettez
au québec les ciseaux s'accouplaient
lui-même vinci g5 se sent plus
peut-être mais nous on a dit que
maintenant mais il faut prendre les
vrais rêves alors je viens tu donnes le
premier alors tu as inventé règles
fabien dans quelques instants je vais te
faire l'amour à c'est la version la
version du jeu n'est pas de l'amour
maternel
je veux juste vous utilisez un peu c'est
ça pendant trois secondes
[Musique]
4 ça c'est pour qu'ils aient la vidéo
puisqu'il faut vraiment qu'ils voient ça
du coup moi j'ai peur parce que je sais
pas ce que ça et j'ai pas vu j'étais
assez clair ok est ce que tu veux qu'on
se fasse la version de mongolie avant de
rattaquer le chiffon me
en variante le latium mongolie jeunesse
pas répondre parce que ma réponse est
oui ok voir l'amour de mongolie l'ananas
banshee c'est une sorte de chifoumi de
mongolie c'est assez rare parce que eux
ils ont ils bougent même pas les truites
ya pas dans le dos et tout ça se joue
avec trois doigts
en gros tu fais ça ou ça ou ça sachant
que le pouce bah lui lui il bat lui et
après c'est une boucle
est-ce que game is khan qui jouent à ce
jeu du coup peut-être avant qu'il
envahissait tout l'europe
je vais axer ses collègues toi là-bas et
hop
si le lot il avait fait ça y est tu vois
j'ai gagné je suis au dessus de chf 1 2
3 1 2 3 donc là je te bats comme ça fait
la boucle 1 0123 nature bas 1 2 3 je
sais pas pourquoi j'avance thé view 1 2
3 1 2 3 la timba 1 1 2 3 1 2 3 1 2 3
attends c'est ok mais là non on a fait
le même non j'ai fait là haut à au
dernier le network
bon ben on va se battre au nom
ça fait deux c'est toi tu - c'est tout à
fait ça toi tu vas lui oui mais j'avais
déjà deux points non mais si jamais les
airs de poupée mais non mais c'est quand
j'entends les commentaires non je crois
pas qu'ils trichent boxe thaï fortiche
on va passer à la version de david leur
slot glace qui en 2005 a créé la version
ultime de l'oeuvre et variantes jouable
du chiffon mis à cette figure comme vous
pouvez le découvrir ici
il y a donc le feu la pierre l'eau l'air
le papier l'eponge et les ciseaux tu
sais qu'on va devoir vérifier à chaque
fois je le disais on n'a qu'à mettre ici
au sol donc on joue ce qu'on veut et on
prend le second de voir tant à gagner
quoi les symboles basse et le feu c'est
ça en fait c'est pas dégeu portion autre
temps spot qui on aurait dit un chien tu
sais les petits chiens qui aboient
ok c'est juste et rembourser le bol
papillon cfrr c'est comme ça et on aura
deux bras le corps le long à démarrer
je suis une cascade je suis obligée de
ce code
mais je suis jeune aux codes chifoumi
alors moi j'ai fait du feu toi t'as fait
quoi
j'ai fait les bons chez feydeau non taëf
et les plonge donc en fait le feu bad
éponge
ils étaient près de 3 le caillou éclater
les fonds mais pourquoi la bascule à la
flèche qui veulent son départ flexi
multidevises bien chez un gros vraiment
cailloux si fou me martin a pris un
traditionnel tous les deux battus jusqu
à concilier on regarde vasilescu mais je
dois dire toi si tu oublies que pourrais
je te bats je suis l'air mais non tu
fais dépendance huile est rare est bon
c'est comme ça
schumi c'est quoi ça c'est le feu mais
ces trois doigts le feu moi c'est l'air
l'air celle de remettre le feu l'air c
gepa fait que j'ai fait le papier ait un
nom 3 2 oui on vous remet juste vite
fait les actions en récap si jamais vous
voulez y jouer fait un screen de ça dans
votre téléphone
allez-y qu'en maintenant alors là là
c'est juste pour le fun il y en a qui
soient amusés en fait après à faire la
version incrémenté en fait cas de pluie
5 de plus exa ça atteint sans une
possibilité alors vous vous voyez en
plein écran toi tu vois un tout petit
comme ça et donc tu as an une
possibilité d'action comment ma main
peut faire sans une forme différente ça
c'est vrai que j'ai pas pensé aux formes
des mains tralala t'imagines en fait tu
joues une fois déjà faut savoir qui a
gagné et après une interprétation non
parce qu'on avait dit que si le doyen
peut replier comme ça on fait un truc et
où c'est chaud oui moi je veux tout le
temps perdu
c'est toi qui parles bien japs séquelles
non ça ce laboratoire ichikoh ça c'est
un laboratoire japonais ils ont inventé
un robot mon gars je vous fait voir des
petits vides et en même temps c'est un
robot qui gagne à tous les coups au
chiffon et en fait ils l'anticipent le
geste il a une caméra qui interprète le
mouvement à la dernière seconde que toi
tu vas faire sinon comment tu décontract
tama et ça se passe d'un sur un millième
de seconde
et du coup lui réagi en conséquence mais
à l'oeil humain tu as l'impression que
les gestes ils sont faits en même temps
donc c'est de la triche en fait moi
c'est de la triche mais c'est bien fait
quand même on peut faire un mois un peu
en gros ce jeu ça vient de lamoura qui
en patois italien veut dire les
cornichons à c'est-à-dire retard c'est
le routard renta tu as les joueurs alors
ça se joue plutôt à plat sur la table
tu peux le faire aussi comme ça mais il
joue vraiment à plat sur une table parce
qu'ils n'ont pas trop le thème tu vois
c'est un peu violent comme j'ai pu il
l'a d'entre zéro et cinq doigts
[Musique]
la vie est comme ça choix chat et en
faisant ça ils vont annoncer un chiffre
ou un nombre entre 0 et 10 qui doit être
une estimation du cumul les doigts que
tu as mis plus les doigts un délire que
ton partenaire à lyon on va faire une
partie en trois coups on va faire juste
trois courts 3 coup d'essai vous voyez
et après on va regarder un extrait de
eux quand ils jouent entre à ce jeu
depuis leur plus jeune âge
alors c'est parce que ils disent même
pas de troie parce qu'ils enchaînent
mais nous on va être beaucoup trop lent
dont 10 1 2 3 on dirait un deux trois
plus enfin après on dit le nom à de 3,10
par exemple un peut pas être dit si tu
fais de par contre je te préviens c'est
vrai si nos otages a deux trois quarts
est donc là j'ai le point ça vaut bien
cela vient chanter moi j'aime bien
chanter on a deux trois cinq blessés ou
tard à 2 3 8 2 1 1 2 3 aux 1 2 3 8 à 3 4
1 2 3 5 1 2 3 2 à 2 3 1 3 litre à 2 3
benjamin pu faire 0 à 2 3 0 au non avec
le hic on appelle regardez la vidéo on
dit [ __ ] ils ont dit ils vont trop
vite ils sont bénins mais en fait on
devient vite rapide et vénère je te fais
voir le
[Musique]
mais c'est beaucoup trop fou voilà vous
aurez découvert l'amour là où l'amour
ils appellent ça est-ce qu'on peut
terminer cette vidéo en disant que tu
aimes l'amour williams oui mais est ce
que ça t'a plu oui est ce que tu es
content d'avoir payé à hubert pour faire
que ça avec moi aujourd'hui
oui bah moi j'avais envie en tout cas
cet été de faire juste une vidéo un
petit loup je vous présentais plein de
bahreïn de l'ue chifoumi que vous pouvez
faire avec vous un peu partout parce que
l'intérêt quand même c'est que seul truc
que tu as menée avec toi c'est des
doigts oui par contre faire l'amour là
du coup dans l'eau dans le train c'est
peut-être un peu violent fait que plutôt
discrète à cette finale que soient les
versions finales
merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo merci à displayed avoir sponsorisé
cette vidéo vous avez toutes les infos
autour de moi et sûrement dans la
description et puis abonnez-vous à la
chaîne de jokes est bonne si vous ne
connaissez pas des vidéos cool
abonnez vous aussi à cette chaîne je
m'appelle famille lucas et si je vous
mets deux vidéos une c'est sûr comment
gagner ou chifoumi et l'autre c'est la
dernière vidéo qu'est sorti j'ai même
pas envie d'en parler tellement il faut
que vous la regardiez à très bientôt
ciao